hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to the Fazbear no the
glitched attraction the Fazbear glitched
attraction this is the full release of a
game that I played a while ago that I
was very impressed by because it put
Five Nights at Freddy's into the style
of an escape room and I like that very
much I miss having escape games I know
they still exist and I just haven't been
playing them but my list of games to
play keeps getting out of date I
interrupt this broadcast to bring you a
very quick bulletin this is on sale
right now Link in the description I was
supposed to promote this forever ago and
I don't have a lot of time right now and
I gotta get this video up and it's
already late and I'm uh I'm splicing
this in right now if you want the king
of Five Nights at Freddy's YouTube
statue you can get it in the description
below it's on sale now it was on sale
two days ago ah this is why no one
sponsors me Link in the description new
game replay level back background
I can get different background
battle pass extrus
[Music]
what uh where am I
oh man I'm wobbly
I got knobbly knees
Gallery I can't go in I haven't gotten
anything all right man you
I don't know why I keep trying to do
everything before I actually do anything
whatever shut up go go new game go yes I
want to start a new game
I don't know if it's going to put me in
the suit
normal
casual now I don't know if it's gonna
put me in the same level that I started
with before
but it was a bedroom before so it may or
may not be in the same theme I don't
really know
booty just left the new Fazbear
attraction
2032 that's the Year my friend take
everything and come here you have to see
this take everything a location was that
you would take everything what do you
mean take everything to send you the
location go tonight what do you mean
Kyle Kyle what are you talking about
Kyle what do you mean take everything my
fridge do I need to think about whatever
what do I need to take water
trail mix what do you need
good what am I look is that a hand that
better be a hand is that my hand I don't
think I took everything most of the
important tips appear here and on the
game over wow
I'm gonna need those oh
no joke excuser welcome to the renewed
and redesigned Fazbear attraction here
you will experience all the creepy
stories made by lunatic haters so
Fazbear entertainment since 1987 where
the robots come to life a murderer roams
the place and accidents happened in the
back rooms do not link to the 2027
accident if you really think you are
prepared for this journey where you may
experience things such as your head
injuries heart attacks and their
variations join us right now for a price
of only
14.99 ping will also make us not
responsible for any of the symptoms
mentioned before
okay sure I'll call again thank you
you're welcome before I open the door
for you please give all your belongings
to my maid in the other window oh where
how long have you been there
your mate I don't know if I want to give
it to your mate here excellent no that's
my everything I brought everything for
here experience where's everything I
heard
[Music]
you're gonna give that back right I
didn't just pay you 15 and then hand
everything I own to your mate right
this is going swimmingly
[Music]
no fun oh I don't like it
introducing tip manager more tips what
do you mean whoa your best friend during
this adventure the tip manager this
incredible technology will help you get
through all the rooms of the attraction
giving you essential tips and hints
about the level you are about to play
this introduction will teach you how to
use and understand the tip manager
properly
check all the tips before starting the
level try to understand the tip before
checking the next one
what do you mean check the background
images
what
feel free to look over the room before
starting
you finished the internet
meet your second best friend I don't
want to meet my second best friend
those weren't really tips
[Music]
I gotta say in all my years of playing
Five Nights at Freddy's in all of my
time playing other fan games in all of
my time playing the official games or
anything to do with Five Nights at
Freddy's I have never found myself
standing in front of the actual stage
where the actual animatronics from the
original game were playing and singing
and moving like this the this is a new
experience for me I have I'm not joking
unless I'm stupid and someone pulls up
evidence of this I have not seen this
[Music]
Hi how are you well
seems really dark when it gets dark is
that a stack of pizzas I don't think I
want to eat those hello
hey it's you from the poster wow that's
pretty great you're you guys are kind of
big don't run don't yell don't scream
don't poop on the floor stick listen mom
don't touch Freddy don't hit leave
before dark thank you management okay
thank you management so
I don't know exactly what you want me to
do oh oh okay
thank you
[Laughter]
okay I'm gonna go now I think
oh
I don't know if I should crawl in the
Chute I don't know if that's what I was
supposed to do
it seems very odd
well we're in the thick of it now and
there's nothing we can do to stop being
in the thick of it so in the thick of it
we shall remain
oh it is this is what I recall this is
what I remember oh frick you oh freaking
oh no okay curtains hold the curtains to
keep them closed
golden suit e looking at the suit to put
it on I don't see any suit
uh I don't remember how to play this one
Freedom complete the puzzles and get out
of this room before someone gets you or
time Runs Out
interesting I'll keep them close so when
there is Fred Bear there I keep those
closed I need to put on a suit
before that
[Music]
interesting yeah I remember this from
the demo but I just don't remember oh my
God I'm so bad at those I'm so bad at
those wait a minute that's that's
twisted up anyway how would I be able to
do that
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay all right seems as good as any uh
but I'll probably find I don't know here
we go
what do I need to do
oh
wait is that all I need to do well
that's much easier because
I definitely wouldn't have the patience
to do anything else
all right
I should probably oh
[Music]
I forgot about everything that was
happening here oh oh why stop Whoa stop
hold on stop stop put it on I'm not
putting it on put it on put put I'm
trying to put I'm trying to put it on
I'm sure I was literally trying to put
it on it wouldn't let me put it on
I was trying to put it on I was really
trying to but you didn't
it will be hidden find it and press it I
don't like this tip my tip's not nearly
as cool all right whatever let's do this
I guess
okay all right we kept most of my
progress
or at least it didn't undo a lot of it
uh
okay you stop you you're fine you you're
okay
[Music]
stop
that's mostly done is that done no
there we go stop nope
oh it doesn't do it
it's not doing it it's not doing the
thing with the thing put the thing on
the thing
why is that not doing that why is that
not doing that why is it not doing me
this suit why can I not do this suit why
is it not give me the suit
I'm sorry what did you just tell me it's
not working
what why is it not working
oh I need to click and hold that's right
oh how do I get out oh God wait how do I
get up
okay I got it now I got it I'm in it to
win it
oh God damn it I just so happened to
luck out and it'd be super close before
no stop
you're fine oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] put it on
but okay
oh
this is uh
hello can I please oh
my God move move move
why is that so cumbersome to do it is so
cumbersome
it is incredibly cumbersome to do that
stop whatever you're doing everyone just
shut up for a moment oh my God shut up
go away go away hurry go away
go away okay we're fine
okay I survived one cycle oh my God
don't do that
you
hello oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh God I'm boned
oh no
oh no oh that looks close wait that
looks a lot closer than it was before
oh God please please
why are you closer I can't tell I can't
tell
that's probably fine
uh
[Music]
stop it
[Music]
holy [ __ ] stop
I wish there was more feedback on that
particular action oh shut up shut up
stop stop
stop
stop what has happened what is that what
is that what is that what is that what
is happening what is any of that holy
[ __ ] what is that what is that what is
that what is happening
what was that
stop what was that about what was that
about
what was that about
kidding me you kidding me is that done
it looks done nope
thumbs upside down okay is that done
it looks done I don't know I don't know
I don't know
freaking out man stop
oh boy
all right
um little confused as to what I need to
do
okay so the well that's surprising
oh well this is going to be a problem
oh this is an immediate problem Oh this
is an immediate problem can I please oh
God flashlight now flashlight now
flashlight now holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh my
God seizure inducing Okay so
I did something
I don't know what oh interesting
interesting key
I got one key
okay that's one of them open I don't
know where the other one is I unlocked
this I think these all look okay they
look okay
everything looks fine there
is everything fine I don't know
what's happening
oh right
oh [ __ ] oh frick oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm just assuming I can turn that off as
soon as I do that uh so this is now both
unlocked right open what is this oh
there
oh
God
okay did I do it seven five three seven
one three okay
holy [ __ ] stop
753-713 okay seven five three seven one
three I'm just waiting for this guy to
be a dick
uh
one three God damn it just go away
frick
oh frick
[Music]
oh why are you silent why are you silent
why was he silent why was he silent why
was he silent it will be hidden
[Music]
okay well that could have gotten better
but now I know what I'm doing
[Music]
stop okay so I just need to very
regularly get him
other than that it's fine
[Music]
and I should run I suppose
be a good idea anyway
button here I don't know what that
button do
not 100 sure about that one
this piece there
it's probably not the same code although
I don't know if I need to press it from
a distance that that's kind of douchey
whoop
man that's
inconvenient and silent
foreign
shut up
shut up
why is it happening stop this stop these
dungeons stop it until you stop it damn
it
oh my goodness please let me get my
flashlight out please oh God where are
they where are they
where are they I don't see them are they
going down I'm coming down
okay I'm alive somehow holy
[ __ ] that nonsense
thankfully they've been kind of merciful
God damn it whoa no oh my God you oh wow
so don't do any of that okay four one
one six six oh
411-660 okay got it
four one one six six oh
what oh we did I got a hammer
everyone back off I got a hammer oh [ __ ]
oh shoot
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm out I'm out [ __ ] I'm out
I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out
I'm out I'm out I'm out holy crap yeah
I'm the best what is this Utah news
Fazbear opens again the abandoned place
of Fazbear has
then reopened as a horror escape room
[Music]
oh no
lockers use lockers to hide not all of
them are opened Freddy's Music Box oh
Freddy's got a music don't over wind it
Freedom cleaned up okay all right let me
take a look at this
not all of them are open wow I couldn't
even see what happened oh hi
all right whatever you say man
so if not all of them are open good God
it's hard to see once I'm in there oh
God also I still have my hammer
okay
[Music]
foxy you okay
oh I don't think a glitch makes your
entire skin disappear
hello
okay whatever you say man let's just try
it because I don't know what I'm
supposed to do
all right so there's puzzles right
there's definitely puzzles there's
puzzles
puzzly puzzles wind the music box or not
okay
that's not good
whoa don't press that oh oh oh oh no oh
I'll punch you punched me you really
just punched me did you punch me
did you punch me really I'm just gonna
go
I didn't even get close to what I should
have done so I know that I'm not even
near what I should be
God oh God
oh God God okay so you're really not
giving me a whole lot to work with okay
is there something on the walls is there
something on the walls
in case there's something so I need to
get a code four oh fourth why holy frick
hello bye okay so the fourth number so
that was that was definitely a straight
up clue fourth number or a fourth symbol
is the thing
hi
okay that's not important
fourth symbol is that I thought I saw
another Post-It note somewhere over here
there we go six is spring fourth is
arrow to the right six is spring there's
another one okay
first one is uh sinusoidal
so it's sinusoidal blah blah Arrow blah
spring
[Music]
how far so good
three okay so it's uh sinusoidal
something jagged
Arrow something spring is that all I
have to do is this orbit around
oh where did you come from
oh okay well that you know you didn't
tell me any of this about loud noises
near events I heard the globe
you tell me I just got lucky
up into that point I mean I guess not I
didn't get very far but I got four of
the symbols already toichika is more
forgetful than you think well I thought
toichika was an idiot but mean right
hook if you know what I mean
really mean okay number one sinusoidal
couldn't possibly be the same code could
it no four is
jagged
I mean you idiot oh
that's quite a punch that's quite a
punch that's quite the punch
don't do that again please I'm asking
nicely if I'm never gonna get this maybe
if I get five of six I can just guess
but even that would be tough okay six is
sinusoidal okay six is sinusoidal five
is Jagged okay
so it looks like the symbol stickers are
always in the same place so it's Jagged
tiny soil
Arrow okay Arrow Jagged sinusoidal dot
dot Arrow da jagged sinusoidal
hello I don't know where oh that's the
vent okay okay
Gap
dot Arrow uh jagged sinusoidal
[Music]
oh there we go
okay that was a four on the curly q so
I've oh it was Gap uh oh my God oh my
God it was Gap
curly
uh Arrow no Gap Arrow curly
jacket sinusoid
oh my God oh my God don't do this don't
do this
oh Gap uh Arrow curly jagged sinusoidal
that means that's five of six
Gap
uh
Gap something era oh frick
overick Ulfric
oh frick
I I don't actually I have to hide it
would be the only other symbol that
there isn't is
right whatever symbol there's not is the
second one Gap
something Arrow curly Jagged sinusoidal
that's what it is
[Music]
oh my God don't don't okay
oh please let me have this
holy [ __ ] oh she's there gold God no no
no
how am I supposed to do this if she's
over there kind of presents a problem I
guess I just need to follow her
I need to follow her path unless she
turns around
thank you
okay
well
that's unfortunate
oh god there she is
but this is my chance okay taking my
chance this is my chance
yes do not turn around
Gap duh
Arrow
curly Jagged sinusoidal
Frick oh my God yes go go go go oh my
God go faster go faster holy [ __ ] go
faster
oh my God no no no no no no what are you
doing what are you doing go get dude oh
what is this what is this no no no no
[Applause]
you're just hi
I had it
I beat that in my heart of hearts but in
the realities of the real it will have
to wait until the next episode I know
how to beat it and I will beat it in the
next episode you can rest your shoe for
that thank you for watching more from
that fan games in the description
goodbye
[Music]
foreign